this is all nonsense i'm here to say
inside a piece of paper is going to make
me leave don't care
they've turned all the cops in to meet
her maids and i think it's cute
well to me it's it looks like just a
power play on them uh trying to to scare
us because the charter rights and
freedoms that says we can peacefully
protest and that's basically saying that
our charter of rights and freedoms is
wrong uh it's saying that we're
unlawfully here
when we're not it's still peaceful and i
don't even care
i know i'm not doing anything wrong i'm
protesting peacefully i think it's
another uh scared tactic and
trying to
gear people into leaving
um
we're doing everything we're doing here
is 100 peaceful and within our charter
rights
and uh if anybody's gonna be breaking
the laws
it's them the the officer that give it
to me uh wouldn't even explain what the
letter was he just said all the
information was on the letter and
basically i was just to read the letter
so at that if you can't tell me what the
letter's about um how am i supposed to
take the letter seriously every couple
days there's a new scare tactic uh
you know the other day the emergency
act was in place and that scared the
guys beside me
uh they couldn't afford having their
bank account seized
again this is a beautiful protest so i
don't understand why that would happen
and then
the next day this is what we get some of
us
they might gonna be intimidated by this
some of the
by the losing their insurance
but those who are willing to give their
life for this cause
you need more
much more than uh
beat return with the rest with fines
with
losing the insurance
stuff like that
even somebody
can go take my house i don't care
i don't care at this point probably my
my bank account is froze not because i
i actually don't even care i'm broke
financially anyway so
take it who cares oh yeah we're not
going anywhere
i'm not moving i'm staying all the way
i think i have a son i don't wanna i
don't want him seeing that handcuffs but
i'm not i'm not too scared i'm not doing
anything wrong it's still peaceful this
is the price you pay for freedom
you know you gotta do what you what do
you very believe
as long as
we were afraid of eight pieces of paper
we had no business company i live here
now i'm gonna change my address